[Musique]
j'ai rencontré un homme au bord de
l'eau un jour
d'été il me demanda de faire un tour en
bateau je refusais
il avait une drôle de tête un petit nez
en trompette et des
yeux
bleus il vint s'asseoir près de moi sur
la plage un jour
d'été il me demanda
caressé mon
visage je
refusais il avait un coup de
soleil du sable dans les
oreilles et des
yeux
bleu il regarda longuement vers la mer
un jour
d'été puis il me dit venez je vous offre
un
verre je
refusais il n'avait pas bonne
mine des doigts pleins de
nicotine et des
yeux
bleu
il me dit je viens d'étrangler ma
femme un jour
d'été accompagnez-moi sur les lieux du
drame je
refusais il avait un chapeau de
paille autour du cou une
médaille et des
yeux bleus
je me disais c'est quelqu'un qui
divague un jour
d'été il se leva et entra dans les
vagues sans se
retourner il disparut dans
l'écume je ne vis plus son
costume mais ses
[Musique]
yeux
bleus